hello in DC how we doing cool there's
people here because I cannot see a thing
I have a blue dot it it's like stay away
from the light Niall your time is not
now it'll be later in the bar rice this
is the psychology of social engineering
if you do not recognize the title you're
probably in the wrong talk and you don't
get to leave because I can see who all
people leaves iid only thing I can see
if there's a person with a Mac up there
which I know cuz I can just see a little
white Apple that's cool thanks at least
I know there's one person here right
this is a non-technical talk that I'm
gonna try and take you up a bit and
we'll have a bit of fun my job and whole
thing is to break your brain or what's
left of it after the last two days so I
when I put forward this talk I go
psychology or social engineering people
go les I this is gonna be boring check
it up now so hacking the human OS is a
much better way of doing this cuz you
know we are currently in the Vista stage
of our releases of OSS we're kind of
there were kind of not people are very
broken they're also the most vulnerable
part of any given system and I'm gonna
show you how to break them or how people
do it to you so I first off I do need a
bit of help because I don't know how
many people are here when everyone who's
got a phone I'm just kind of lighted up
and I can just see what's going on I've
got it's cool I can see three from this
is oh wow there's actually people all up
the back there's a person lost hi thank
you all very much that at least gives
you an idea of how many people are here
there's 12 to take off my shoes if I
want to get to 20 right this is me my
name is Niall I am the head of cyber
security for Norway at Capgemini I'm an
MVP as the insider as your advisor all
those cool titles I Eve tweet a lot at
an Merrigan so please tweet me if you
like my talk if you didn't like my talk
yeah just come and talk to me over a
pints and you buy the first round we'll
see where we end up and I can emails
website all that so I built this talk
and I thought you know it's a real fun
thing because I take stuff
real life I see how people react to
certain things and I watch a loss and
when I was building this talk I had this
slide on my computer and my six-year-old
rocks in showing me this is amazing
piece of Lego that I'm very proud of
because he likes Lego as much as I do
and it's a really good excuse like
honestly honey I bought the Lego for him
niall it says 16 years plus he'll grow
interest once I'm finished with this and
he goes Papa Papa Papa there's a
mikhalev I said use your English words
and he goes there's a fox yes there's a
Fox on your screen
and he goes I said yes there is what
else do you see he goes a fox I said yes
he goes look closer and he goes what do
you mean look closer it says do you see
feet elbows buns hair he's like what
where do they come from and I said this
is this is people and he goes there's
people in there Fox and I'm like there's
people in that Fox and he goes okay you
could see his little mind exploding a
little bit here it was like as the Lego
was dropped to this stage and now he was
very fascinated by this people Fox and I
went and he goes what is this puppet I
said it's art or so my wife's or your
mother says and and he goes just Arthur
are there people and everything else and
I says no but you can look and so now he
was frantically looking around all the
different things now I was trying to
find people and my wife Rock City goes
what did you do to him and I said watch
me what I do he's outside there
scrambling around look is that person in
there I showed up this picture he's a
six-year-old his imaginations running
wild and he goes okay but it is a thing
of once you see something like this and
you know what to look for
it becomes a plain sight I problem you
go of course right how many of us have
had this kind of thing where you know I
show you a solution to a problem you go
of course it was always that or you open
the fridge and you're looking for buffer
and you're scanning and
scanning and scanning you're like I
don't can't find the butter you close
the fridge two seconds later you open it
but there is how many of you've done
that you know it could be a fridge full
of butter
you wouldn't find it and when your wife
comes in she goes are you stupid I said
I'm probably blind I just can't see us
and she goes well it's right there so
good but it is because we start becoming
more aware and this is like we're
example we see scams being pulled on
people and you go of course so they're
kind of the big one for everyone in
Norway who has been the Microsoft our
the call center and Microsoft ringing up
and telling you have a virus and if
you've got that and if you played with
them and if you just wished you could do
more this is the one of my colleagues he
goes I've got one I've got one I said
what have you got what have you got he
goes I've got one of the guys from
Microsoft ringing me as as and and we
all went into panic mode
who's got the oldest vm in the house
someone fire up windows 95 okay windows
three one we were literally seeing could
we install windows 3 one and a vm it do
it just like you know in confuse the
crap or them but for us that was common
but for example my grandmother are my
wife's grandmother rains me because now
i'll the people from Microsoft rang me
again and they set up a virus on my
computer and says well you don't I've
I've sorted all that out and he and she
goes why do they keep ringing me and I
said it probably has something to do
with your number is like four seven zero
zero zero zero one seven and she goes
why was it I says well it's the 17th
number in that string so it's probably
that's what they're doing he goes do you
mean there's someone manually typing I
said no now god bless her soul but she
it was just that she couldn't understand
it now I what I want to show you here a
little bit more is that we are not
technical people are not are not the
first people to use social engineering
to get their way marketing and sales
have been doing this for years
alright so what are we on screen here it
is a perfume and meals called a men's
cologne how do you sell men's cologne
without smell-o-vision okay think about
this
I put this something in your own I bet
that smells lovely I wonder and what
they've positioned here is they've got
this very nice man with his tie slightly
ajar right five o'clock shadow
a woman seductively lenient Whittier and
going I'd like a hamburger
it's a pg-13 show kids now so it is Ben
this is very subtle by a lot of these
standards you have a bottle there with
boss the scent and you can tell by the
dark colour it's probably a more
nighttime ascent even by the way they're
positioning it it's probably a more suit
scent you know it's not something you
wear to the beach instead this might be
something you wear to the beach okay so
this is where Dolce and Gabanna says
hair hold my beer I can strip a man and
we'll put him on a boat and make him
look amazing all right and if you wear
the scent you can be him now I can
guarantee you if I could be him using
that my wife would be bathing in it
meeting me in it every day she goes
we're going to the beach honey all right
okay but you can see they did they said
they put a man on a Gian bow or boat in
the Aegean piercing blue eyes the whole
laughs and they said we're gonna make
people aspire so they're selling you an
idea not selling you a smell they're
selling you an aspiration that you can
be this person by wearing this scent
they're doing it the thing is they
weren't they haven't been doing this for
a long time because back in the 60s men
smelled like sweat barnyards daus pins
they smelled horrible women smells
lovely
men smells like you dragged them through
a bush backwards you know they had an
allergic reaction to soap boss one
company decided they would change all us
and has anyone know what company that
was think so close your eyes think and
go back and remember the first male
smell Old Spice Oh nearly go a little
bit deeper
and you're probably gonna think Bruce
ever remember the green bottle of Bruce
it is a weapon of mass destruction okay
you put that on
no one can smell anything else in the
room very popular in student bars put on
Brut and the thing is if I tell you
about Brut your old one oh yeah it
smells like dad
granddad had that it's the first mask
and smell and how do they market this
very simple this works fairly obvious
for men it smells like a man all right
what are we gonna do well guys we can
only sell it if they like it so what we
do it smells like a man job done right
dude everyone knows the old phone by the
way I get a bit kind of little nostalgic
my son says we wanna goes papa why don't
we put phones on the walls we can always
find them I was looking good good idea
son good idea don't show him the old
photos so another company says we can do
better and they doubles down and that
was hello Lee look at your man now back
to me
sadly he isn't me but if he stopped
using ladies scented body wash and
switched to Old Spice he could smell
like he's me look down back
you're on a boat with the man your man
could smell what's in your head back at
me I am it's an oyster with two tickets
to that thing you love look again the
tickets are now diamond
anything is possible when your man
smells like old spice and not a lady I'm
on a horse so they Double Down smell
like a man man it's like if you're gonna
do it reiterate us no sir they were very
effective and these two companies have
fairly much revolutionized how we think
of male Cologne because before that it
was not something was being done and
this has gone on now they're not the
only people that do this type of
suggestion that you can be having in you
know you can smell like a man or have an
inspirational thing we also have things
like for example boxer shorts so these
are Calvin Klein boxer shorts modeled by
a very strange boy Canadian I hear and
the thing is they're selling an
aspiration you can look like this if you
wore these unfortunately these and
gentlemen we're more likely to look at
this I am super proud of this slide it
is so much more normal that that was
what we would look now the thing is
they're cheating here because they
photoshopped him and as you will notice
they enlarge certain parts of his
Anatomy his bicep yeah so there you go
there's a whole lot of people that put
in rides inside in the bucket
I even blind and scarred from this talk
right car companies also do it so this
is a Kia SUV this is parked outside a
lovely house with an exceptionally good
manicured lawn all right my first
criticism of this photo how the hell did
they park the car there without driving
it over the lawn and when you spend that
much time parking is why did you end up
on the concrete ok so they are sending a
message here you know they're sending a
very simple message you can park like
this outside your house but you'll never
make it inside ok so this is why you
should not buy a Kia SUV anyone have a
Kia SUV
anyone willing to admit it are you in
park like this
alright now they do this because the
thing is it's selling sex cells it's a
very base instinct for humans as always
what we are after nearly all the time
but it is a case of that with this
they're selling okay they are trying to
make an SUV or a key SUV very sexy and
that's what they're attempting to say
that you could be that person if you own
said car other car companies like for
example BMW they put this car scuse me
they put this car and park it like any
per MW person would Park so BMW owners
like to say parking we like to say just
sheer abandonment I left the car
somewhere it's fine it's a BMW now the
thing is I can guarantee you a BMW x6
will have known will never go off road
it might see a speed bump or a curb but
he will never go off road but the
aspiration is by having this type of car
or this vehicle you could park wherever
you lights okay or you could go off-road
but in in reality reality most of us are
never going to do this because if you
buy a BMW x6 it's not the offroad II
type of car you're gonna go where are
you but it's an aspiration so you know
they turn to the great nor the great
Atlantic Way in Norway the amazing
bridge they try and get these of all the
cars driving over if you look at any
type of car they'll all say that you can
beat us you know really safe driver or
you can be this really sporty driver and
they're always selling you the
aspiration by driving this car you will
be happy and have fun in whatever mode
you like now it this is where we're
selling you a solution before but now
what if I also sold you the problem and
the solution in the same package
okay and this is men's magazines or for
example men's health now to get what
they call cover ready fish takes an
amazing amount of effort you have 90
percent of getting six pack abs are
based off getting in the kitchen as you
can see I'm working very well on it in
that department now the thing with this
is they are also using tricks of type
town shadowing lighting etc and
dehydration to get there but you notice
that they're saying some summer
shred get ripped in just 20 minutes a
day so you can be as ripped to this
person by only spending 20 minutes how
many of you go regularly to the gym how
many of you would spend only 20 minutes
there okay one really do you just get
lost Park like Park like the BMW walk in
walk back out park out again or do you
just like by viewing a Kia SUV no see
people people the key to humor is
keeping the jokes going the whole way
through the talk now if you're here and
you think okay this is kind of bad it is
absolutely nothing compared to women's
magazines because this is a typical
problem they are selling you a very
psychological problem and then offering
you solution so eat up and slim down
okay like it makes no sense
all right now I'm this this particular
slide is kind of you know they it gets
me every time because when every time I
see it I find something new in us
because I'm looking at this woman she is
fantastically attractive everything's
done right the whole lot it's still
photoshopped and then the messaging
behind it is is just criminal you know
if you were to say this to someone
they'd look at you in the slap you but
this is what they're doing they're
selling you a problem you didn't even
know you had and then they're saying
well by its subscribing that the fact
that you have this problem we also have
the solution all right so this is a
common thing especially within magazines
they will do this all the time to kind
of say let us give you a problem you
didn't know you had and then sell you
the actual solution all right and it is
a common social engine technique imagine
doing that to someone saying you've got
something wrong with you here I've got
the fix for it
imagine going up to someone and saying
that's their face but they can do it in
the magazine no problem so we're going
to look now at some of the kind of
sociology or psychological things and
one them's our we have these massive
amount of problems in our head which we
call bias bias is I would like to do it
I think in a specific way therefore it's
rice or something appeals to me
therefore it's correct okay we are all
biased in some way it happens it not are
all biases are bad but in general some
biases are very strong for example
racial bias you know looking at someone
based on their on their skin color or
ethnicity you go I don't like that
person it's kind of where would someone
would hear when you hear bias but we
also have a thing called cognitive
biases these are things in our head that
we can break as a social engineer and we
can use them against you to get our way
because ultimately social engineering is
using dirty little tricks to get your
own way okay example in point how many
of you are parents
excellent how many of you tried to feed
fussy eaters
bald on us okay how many of you used the
following trick do you want two pieces
of broccoli or three they're eating
broccoli either way but they think
they've got a choice
and you're all going oh yeah santé
cognitive bias for example Congress won
the major cognitive biases is for
example anchoring anchoring is a very
interesting technique based on the first
piece of information you were given it
becomes the reference point for any
other decision you make with me so far
well let's try it a bit easier how we
choose by comparing with a nearby
reference points do I want left or right
do I want a large so I want - small - I
want Coke do I want a Fanta doing
something else we do this all the time
kids do it every time
he's got more than I have she's got more
than I have I want what she has my kids
anybody all this the time but this is a
common technique and we use this very
effectively specifically in pricing now
here's where you've got a bit of a brain
freeze and I start messing with your
head a little bit so this isn't an
advertising for an iPod Touch what do
you read the first thing you see is the
price the size in the price there two
things are highlighted highlighted 8
gigabytes - 29 32 gigabytes $2.99 64
gigabytes 399 which is the best value
come on
I can wait 32 as from the answers in the
front
everyone's kind of agreeing with 32
right why come on this is this is where
I start breaking your heads a little bit
you know it's not we're not at the party
yes okay let me spell it out most of you
seen okay I have going up 70 dollars for
the 32 gigabytes and I'm getting four
times the space the next one I'm going
up a hundred dollars but I'm only going
up twice the space most likely because
you've read left to right okay you're
you're missing the point that we're
looking at 230 300 and 400 dollars
you're probably reading it as it's still
only 299 it's not 300 and the reason
you're doing this is because the first
point of information which is 229 is
your anchor point of how expensive it
should really be and you probably never
questioned as to why they put 229 there
first
are you a bit scared yes because this is
a common technique how many of you go
for example to a coffee shop and you
will see the prices of a small and
medium and large and you'll go okay and
you'll notice that the small to medium
is a magnificent jump but medium to
large is a smaller jump and you always
go I think I'll have the large because
if you have something as priced at $1
for small $2 for medium and $3 for large
nine times out of ten most people will
go between small and medium but if you
go and say this small is $1 the large
the medium is $2 and the large is two
dollars 50 most people will go for the
large because it is only 50 Cent's more
than the medium which they would always
most likely go for because they'll go
for the middle one because the reference
point that they're using is am I getting
a good deal so by using this type of
technique we can sell more things and
Apple are masters at it let's look at
this one it's the iPhone so you're
probably reading Wi-Fi for 99 $5.99
$6.99 and you're going Wi-Fi in 3G 629
729
a 29 but you're not comparing up and
down you're only reading left to right
because Western society reads left to
right we don't compare up and down
because if the one you want is Wi-Fi in
3G you're starting your base point at
629 and working is more expensive or why
do I want to put myself you're not
probably gonna go oh because if it was
Wi-Fi and Wi-Fi and 3G were side-by-side
I can guarantee you they wouldn't sell
that many Wi-Fi plus 3G because people
will be looking at the common cumbrous
the comparison line is too much for just
3G but they put all the information in
front of you and the worst part is we're
all looking at it going that is crazy
and when you look at this you start to
begin to question how they do pricing if
you want to sell more things you create
an anchor point something that a
customer will go I can reference that
and I now know how plus or minus
expensive it should be if you have two
things it is much easier to compare and
say well is it good or bad if you want
to successfully sell things put three
products on the market price them in
such a way that the middle the one you
want is the most attractive and you know
there's one that's really far off for
the people who don't care about money
kindle did this a lot of other companies
do this they all release in this kind of
scenario and they're not the only one to
do this a lot of other customers do
companies do it like this whether they
will do a sliding scale from most
expensive down to free because they'll
say well most people as you can see bone
feeder 2995 of course we're using the 95
which most people are ignoring so
they're seeing only 29 all right and
they're then going to going okay I don't
really want to spend $200 I don't want
to spend $70 but $30 is okay and it's
better than the free because the pricing
model works on the first page if you're
going down 199 to 299 to 29 or like to
230 is a significant jump and you don't
think you're paying as much as usually
as you would want to or should do it's a
real sneaky little thing then this one
gets me as well as the New York Times so
Noir
what happens as most people start
comparing and then they eventually a
spot the little thing that causes the
problem has anyone spotted it yet huh
different currencies exactly huh let's
try here four dollars fifty what now
the reason I'm using this particular one
they have $8.99 1499 but you get two
things you get the kind of unlimited RQ
didn't see you get extra two gifts and
then there's digital and home access way
back when New York Times offered their
digital subscription for $90 a for six
months they offered their print edition
for a hundred and thirty dollars for six
months and they offered their brain
print and digital edition for a hundred
and thirty dollars for six months so it
was 90 130 and 130 which do you think
most people picked the two things for
130 why best deal was two things for 130
I'm getting I'm getting the 89 I'm
getting the $90 value plus I am only
paying an extra $60 which for something
that should be 130 on its own are off
sorry $40 for something that's under 3
on its own do you think the New York
Times were mad to do that or very clever
I'm hoping people are nodding and saying
very clever why do you think they did
such a thing they offered their digital
edition effectively for free why do they
do that
that's the price they wanted mmm good
answer but no what is the ultimate goal
of a newspaper to sell newspapers so
what do they need to do they needed to
sell the print edition so they made the
print edition a kind of a good value
target and then threw in the digital
edition what do you use to create the
print edition the digital edition so he
already had that so that was going in so
effectively what they did is they said
we're gonna give you two for one but
force you in a way that you think you're
really getting a good deal and we get
what we want
social engineering pricing models are a
bit mental but that's how it works and
it's very common to do it with that in
mind and moving on to kind of like using
social a little social tricks and kind
of things we're gonna go into fishing
everyone heard of fishing yeah if you
teach a person if you teach a person
give a person the fish daily for a day
teach the person out of fish they'll
have money for a lifetime
all right so for many of us we probably
think of fishing we think of like a
Nigerian person in a back room somewhere
what fifty bajillion dollars and he's
they're really trying to help ask that
today you would help them get it out of
the country right spam all that type of
thing we normally call that trolling
that is it is you throw down a net you
hope you catch something you might catch
something who knows but it is highly
ineffective when you're going it's
generally catches the stupid people or
people who have just been caught in the
wrong way or whatever it is very yeah
hit miss and you know sending email is
expensive but how about we use something
like spear phishing so how many you
tweeting today excellent how many you've
used the NDC a hostile hashtag which is
trending grace and how many of you kind
of like put out information that you're
at here you've watched something and
whatever excellence so for me as a spear
Fisher what I would end up doing is I'd
spot who you are look at your user name
kind of find out some information about
you and then send you some information
related to your recent activities and
you think that must be real because they
wouldn't know I was doing that all right
to put it in context when Foursquare was
still a big thing you do a check and you
see check in at Foursquare for Starbucks
you could then work out from LinkedIn
okay who that person was because you
just like you can see their email
address in whatever it's like grace you
use LinkedIn use this do you send them
an email saying oh thanks for your
recent from a spam email you say thanks
your recent draw a check in its
Starbucks we really impress your
business here's a 50 corner
PDF voucher that you can print and get
50 Kroners off your next
drink at us how many people would not
open that mail and double-click the PDF
did you get a free voucher and 50 kroner
after next coffee nice they recognize me
I'm lovely tiny pieces of information
gives me such and I give people such an
insight into your way of working that
you can go cool I can use that now to
attack someone and spearfishing is very
very effective but there's a bigger
version we call it whaling very popular
in Norway and Japan not so popular in
the other part of the world things I
have sent my mother pictures of include
whale niece which he just went what's
that and I said it's very dark steak so
when we do County for example whaling
what we'll do is we'll go after the CEO
now who is the most powerful person in
any company I can't see anyone but you
want try anyone wanna shout it out
this is I know this is really hard with
Norwegian audience but you can try in
Norwegian I understand CTO no the main
the main admin correct the PA to the CEO
is the most powerful person in the
company because what happens there is
they have what they tell the CEO where
to go oh what they're meant to be doing
so when Joan is off in Tokyo and she's
at a meeting I ring John and say hi John
my name is Niall like working Capgemini
I'm I'm looking for Jonah I'm supposed
to have a meeting with her oh she's in
Tokyo now oh all right do you know what
I'll ring her on her mobile thanks very
much two seconds I've got I now know
that Jones out of the country
I know I know can send mails from Joan
to the somebody very high up get Joan
gets a bit pissy when she's in Tokyo and
doesn't get good food and so I send out
you need to send 1 million US dollars to
this account otherwise we will lose the
contract do it now
someone goes oh crap Joan's annoyed some
guy in Ukraine is going da
vodka yeah oh cool $1,000,000 mine agian
friend so but this is very common and we
do and it tiny is important do it on a
Friday 5:00 talk just as month-end
happens when people are really stressed
and want to go home when the idea of a
beer bottle is really appealing and not
the idea of a very angry boss certain
cultures are also very susceptible to
this because they just follow orders or
very hierarchical cultures are very
susceptible to this normally not so much
and norway's a little bit protected
because of the use of either Norwegian
language which is good but the problem
happens is it is all down to human error
alright now we've hopefully many you've
seen this but it is like we all have
this in this corner we have firewalls
encryption antivirus software etc and in
this corner we have date now we all
channel our inner Dave every one of us
channels our inner Dave how many of you
went oh shouldn't click that link how
many of you went now I wish didn't look
that click Beatty title why am I still
looking at image or at three o'clock in
the morning you know we all do this our
inner Dave is a very can be very strong
and laner Dave comes out human error is
a very very powerful tool and we exploit
it very very quickly so the one thing I
always say is human error is the thing
we're looking for and the great thing
about like things like common sense is
it's not very common so we can exploit
that too right I Nev you use LastPass
first up how many of you don't use a
password manager oh boy ok can you send
me an email just with your details you
know why you'd and why you only use one
pass just how I like a signal possible
is there any reason why you don't use a
password manager just being very honest
about this very serious no yes is it
just laziness is just never knew you
should use them squeeze me passphrase
slightly modified ok
really in four languages huh is that all
you sir we must have a discussion well
this is LastPass this is a password
manager this is what people who like to
be secure use not I I will talk to you
little bit about that with the kind of
idea of why I like why language things
are a bit odd but for example this is a
normal login kind of what happens when
they say we need to put in your password
and it says let's inject this password
into your page and this does anyone see
the problem with this it's a website it
is a Chrome extension dot pw : or faster
so it is a website that is actually
emulating a LastPass login so you would
put in your LastPass login email details
whatever and they would have access to
you all your your password credentials
this is bad and this is what is known as
pixel-perfect fishing now this is a
common type of fishing technique we also
have things like for example iCloud
normally what would happen is you would
make it so that this would only look on
when you appear just on a I device so on
a small screen so you wouldn't see the
URL it would look like it's coming from
Apple and it like this is what happened
in 2014 a lot of people's accounts were
fish that's why Apple increase their
security but this is a very common
technique another one is for example
there has been unusual activity in your
account please log into the client
purchases of $344 pounds and Harrods and
84 in Hamleys when you get this type of
information what the hell goes through
your head panic and panic is easy to
exploit because of this you know all of
a sudden as the messes are a bit more
like you know personal than email you
get an SMS you look at it you get and
you get like one for Mikey a family you
get on but then you put this on you go
oh then you click on the link and you do
something enough you go but how about
bypassing two-factor authentication on
SMS we recently noticed a suspicious
sign in return for this address
from here if he would light not like to
have your account hacked please reply it
with the six digits you will momentarily
receive with the word stop to this
address how many of you would send back
the six digits quite a few this is a
common way to bypass SMS the tenth
ocation if you have the first part which
is an account password password
credentials and reused as a very common
attack users and it's very difficult to
send SMS you know he's Adam SMS now if
you go right let's go and do voice mail
solicitations you want to do a sample
basically what you do is use the phone
to extract information or data points
that can be used in a later attack let's
do it maybe I'll call your cell phone
provider see if I can get them to give
me your email address I bet they're good
hi I'm actually I'm so sorry can you
hear me okay I my baby I'm sorry my my
husband's like we're about to apply for
a loan and we just had a baby and he's
like it's done by today so I'm so sorry
I can't um call you back uses
information and I can't remember what
email address we use to log account the
baby's in just 30 seconds oops well it
should normally go of it further but it
would normally say what what happened I
have no idea what happened video but
normally what happens and this is a
funny okay so two things have happened
here I have given this talk three times
this presentation has never worked at
NDC I honestly this is the third time
I'm so far we've got further than I've
got in London and Minnesota so far now
so what happened was first thing men and
women all right there's some social
contracts that are brought up
specifically for men we're told to be
gentlemen hold doors for ladies give up
your seat for older older people on
buses all right we're brought up like
this is a common thing so what we're
gonna do now is exploit that so the what
did anyone pick up on the conversation
we've just had a baby and my husband
said get it done now they established
the man as an ass no seriously you did
all right and the woman is in distress
is in trouble needs help humans like to
be helps I like to give help so customer
service agent on the other side goes to
Vermont and kind of goes I can do this
I'll save you and save you from your
husband right and also crying baby okay
when I was younger and I got on a plane
and I'd see a baby I was like oh God
alright then I discovered Bose
headphones and I went whoa
goodbye kids right but crying kids like
so for those you have kids when you hear
a crying child you automatically react
and you know God something's wrong I
need to help okay that there's like it's
mom and dad reflexes kick in I've
everyone seen like you know the mom and
dad reflexes you know you you notice
this as soon as you walk you see parents
walking into a house they start moving
things away from the where they could
fall over from the little Johnny and or
they they spotlight little Johnny's
about to jump off the swing got him and
moms do it like you know got him up
there and you know this it's amazing
it's like they have eyes in their back
of their heads because we have two okay
two children they're all over the place
they tagged him you know the thing here
is that when we use these type of
techniques and where we say it right
you're using a crying baby a person in
distress that we can help and an [ __ ]
husband against you can say this person
is a recipe for saving alright so just
then said right I have got access to
your accounts because I use this crying
baby kind of technique alright we do
this a lot it is a really interesting
technique to be using and what you say
okay let's use the kind of social
contracts against you if someone's meant
to be nice we try to be nice you know
ever meant like for example if you're
there and you're saying oh look at that
person crying so one of the weird things
was I was in Seattle and this little
girl about four wanders out of the Lego
store in floods of tears and panic face
the first thing I do is I go to and say
hi what's wrong I've lost dad
I've lost a night my heart I'm sorry
I've lost that I said where did you find
where did you leave dad said I left dad
in the Lego store so let's let me take
your head and it's got the Lego store
what do you think happens put that for
that context now what what you think
just happened to what was I perceived us
I received perceived as a child molester
you laugh but that's what it was because
no man is allowed to go down and talk to
a child and stand up alone without
anyone else because what was happened
was perception and it didn't matter
whether I was like I would have had a
unit if I'd a uniform on would mean fine
but as a regular guy in the street
standing down and helping a child I
automatically was not assumed to be a
parent or anything else
I was assumed to be doing something bad
because that is the world we live in and
that's the bias kicking in again all
right now I grabbed the girl's hand I
brought her off the leg of store and dad
rushed us out he's got these daggers on
me I'm like she got lost she's really
upset I brought her back because she was
getting very scared don't scare her
anymore
if it was my kids I'd be very happy that
you brought them back he was oh thanks
whoo oh thank you thank you you okay
darling you okay don't what don't run
away for Dad
I got a turnaround because I'm about to
be shot you know this is the US but if
it had been something else if it had
been like it just like I helped no lady
across the road not a problem
small child he doesn't look so good and
that's because we used bias and that's
because of the fact that the social
contract says that you know we're not
supposed to do this we see this all the
time and it's a very unfortunate product
of our society right now when we look at
social engineering we look at other ways
which we can use these dirty little
tricks to get our own ways right so I
put this up on the screen what do you
see what do you see a pregnant woman
what is never associated with pregnant
women alcohol I wasn't expecting that
you just can't be like left right I'm
like alcohol well yeah I suppose you're
right I would have said not being evil
like being evil no one assumes pregnant
women are evil pregnant women are
creating life you know they have more
better things to worry about like
sleeping I'm trying to ensure baby
clothes and all these other things then
worrying about being evil all right so
pregnant women are also something as a
man you are very much kind of trying to
make sure that this is okay right
because we're taught this way parents
brain these values down to kids you know
give up your seat if you see a pregnant
woman honest on the subway or whatever
and allow them to sit down because you
know they're doing something you can't
remember this nowaday you're doing
something you can't yes mom I understand
it was hard if I'm 39 years old you're
still bringing this up never forgives me
I mean but this is a kind of thing for
example you'll open the door you'll deal
help you'll try and be nice you know
it's these are the things we'll do so
this is jack height check is a
penetration tester and social engineer
and she live tweeted this amazing attack
so what she had to do was try and break
into a building and get information from
the building
I just just show it could be done so the
first thing to do is gain a lot of info
on a recon its announced on social media
they're all branches are having a
meeting the HQ social medias gave us
detailed pictures of their badges also
very cool and we did some dumpster
diving dumpster diving going into the
dumpsters finding information now this
is pretty cool just is just standard
recon then jack is looks like this okay
and Jack goes I am I'm not going to get
any dress like this no one's gonna know
they're gonna ask me why I'm here so
Jack needed to get pregnant fast so she
did and she put on a belly and then
inside that belly is all her Wi-Fi
hacking gear she's gonna give birth to a
lovely tribe and router mesh network
twins right and now we've all heard the
old story the easiest way to break into
a building is to be carrying a box and
wearing a high vis vest
ladies and gentlemen it is a little bit
easier all you need to do in carrying
four coffee cups right I don't remember
who said this first but coffee carriers
filled fill hands and open doors the
four in the carrier are filled with
water so imagine very pregnant lady
my ankles are killing me my things are
swollen I just I don't I'm uncomfortable
you open the door
sure in you go so in she goes and she
says between the belly and a bunch of
coffee I had people jumping to open
doors for me because she's exploiting a
couple of things one people are nice to
no one expects a pregnant lady to be
carrying Wi-Fi hacking gear in their
tummy you can now remember my son going
looking for people in places you can
imagine me going no Wi-Fi signal here
how is the kid gonna play pokemon go
inside there okay okay so this is just
an example of using very kind of these
type of attacks against people it's very
handy it works really really really well
but we also use social stereotypes right
so I am Irish so what is the first thing
that comes to your head when I say I'm
Irish alcohol that's exam see where you
can see where the two of you are going
you know pregnant women alcohol Irish
alcohol pregnant Irish person shots okay
but I use it all the time
hi I'm Irish how's it going here I of
Megara top of the mornin to your [ __ ]
that didn't come out well but we use it
all the time because no one expects the
Irish guy to be the hacker in the room
its grace what's he doing I don't know
but apparently our Wi-Fi is dead we're
all connected to me so it's a real good
thing to use because you know you meet
it you meet an Irishman the first thing
new is old you want to go to the Irish
pub we just call them pubs back home you
know and it's really odd but this is
something we do and we can use this
against people because how the Irish a
great craic your most be Paddy's Day is
coming up it's fantastic we're all Irish
that day it's great we're agreeing we're
puking up green beer it's fantastic and
we're that's not what it's meant to be
you must hate the English how did you
know you know to like do you know John
from Cork so dizzy about this tall has
hair
yes SoDo no John it works
automatically you know working it's like
goes the US I am Irish oh my
grandfather's great dog was Irish it's
like that's lovely
where is he from Yahoo --gel what Yahoo
Google no it's called y'all back home so
like this is this is a common thing and
we will use it now so when you see
American cops you think bagels you think
doughnuts and shooting people you know
too too touchy shooting innocent people
sorry my bad
clarification from the yank in the front
that's what you call a team of looks
like you passed out the joke and they
just throw it back to you better better
wrapped up but this is a common thing so
we we do this and of course we do this
all the time when we do social and
racial profiling and or what they call
profiling or I like to call bias and
racism we do this all the time you see a
certain person a person of a certain
color wearing a certain driver gear and
you automatically think oh you back off
because you're afraid we do this all the
time stereotypes are used so when you
have a stereotype that's working in your
favor you play up to it so I ring out
people and I will I know if I ring up
certain countries and I I turn the Irish
accent up to 11 and it's like it
literally this guy just escaped from the
farm 11 hello how's it going I'm trying
to come over to your country you know
and people are going I use me sir I
don't understand what you're saying
you know and it works really well
because they don't think you're gonna do
something bad because Irish people are
never like that at all honest I'll leave
that one hang because that usually works
better in England um there's another
really interesting thing as well as
known as the Benjamin Franklin effect
and this is where I really break your
head so if I was to walk down Karl Johan
offering out 500 kronor notes to people
how many people would you think would
take it very few and why would you think
they did not take the 500 kronor notes
on the Irishman excuse me we don't use
cash
bravo Bravo give that man a round of
applause let's go back oh it's brilliant
old use cash oh yeah well you're not
wrong so getting heckled by the people
know you're getting a bit brave in there
in the dark aren't you brilliant how
they don't use cash I don't know where
to go with this now don't think we're
crazy there we go they'll think you're
Irish okay but if you go and ask someone
for a favor
a small favor all right one the weirdest
thing is they will help you and if you
ask him for a second bigger favor
they're more likely do it for you as
well because they will trust you it is a
really weird thing going out go and
offer help to someone they'll back off
and go what's that what's the catch go
and ask someone I need a little bit of
help I'm can you oh can you also do X
all right and then they'll say great you
need to do this okay oh right okay um
yeah I'll help you because we don't want
to be beholden to people we don't want
to be like in their deaths the same time
using this type of technique it means
that what we'll do is we'll get the
first initial thing person will then say
well if they're asking again they must
really like me and trust me and
therefore I should trust them because
they really like me and all of a sudden
you're going huh
and or salesmen's when they fold the
door you leave you know you're hurting
my foot P that mean okay and now we
start to have a conversation asking for
a favor first leads to more favours
rather than trying to offer help first
which will most likely end in rejection
it is a really weird thing to break
people's head with the idea that if I
ask you for help you're more likely
going to help me more and then I can get
you to do different things that you
wouldn't normally do to put it in
perspective um hi this is Niall here
from Capgemini um listen John I'm trying
to send over a Pio can you open the file
for me and just like verify cuz I can't
get this thing talking about bosses on
my back can if I send you an email with
this PDF will you open it to check and
help me
and most likely John will open said PDF
now PDF will contain something else
it'll crash of course now go Oh John
what happened he goes all my thing
crashed I said oh do you have what
version of Adobe Acrobat
using 700 right I'm using 11 maybe it's
just a problem listen my managers about
to ring me I'll call you back
ask for help get them to infect the
computer I take it over I ring them and
they'll help me and now it's because
I've asked them for a favor where if I
sent the email with something else
they're more likely wouldn't but by me
asking for help they will so all the key
takeaways from this social engineering
is the use of dirty little tricks to get
your own way alright parenting we also
call us sometimes alright are generally
living we use kind of different
psychological sociological ideological
levers to get people's heads in a way
where we can use them against them and
the worst thing it's not overt it's
always quite subtle so if you're always
being presented with something too good
to be true it probably is
and if you read it on the internet it's
probably false ladies and gentlemen
that's the psychology of social
engineering thank you very much so I'll
open the floor to questions yeah was
expecting that please vote put a green
and if you like to put a yellow and if
you didn't like it Karen if you like if
you want to put a red come talk to me
first all right ladies and gentlemen I
thank you so much this has been my last
NDC talk I'm going to take a break for a
year in a piss I want to thank you for
being the last audience I will present
against in Norway for a long time thank
you so much
[Applause]